in this initial i felt like you dropped
three elements and you're like i don't
know what else to do
so one trick that i'll do and you've
seen me do this before is to draw a
block over things
i just want to simplify the layout
because if you look at
the words or the paragraphs they can get
more complicated and then you look at
the words and it's even more complicated
than you look at the letters
you could start to lose a sense of what
the layout is doing so by merely drawing
a
block over the elements that tony has
laid out for us we can kind of see now
the essence of this layout
and if you really think about it this is
just really one group here it just
happens to be broken into
three parts right but it's a very
centered layout
and it is to me a little bit on the
static side
uh usually centered layouts are reserved
for things that are very classical and
they're feeling very traditional
but this layout is neither classical or
nor traditional it's a
it's a magazine about pioneers in design
so we want to honor the content we want
to treat it appropriately
so this is where i'm having some issues
with this layout and
the other thing that i get the feeling
that tony's done here is that he's taken
the type and he's pushed it up into the
corner here
and he's pushed it down into the corner
here and it's
it's not doing anything for me here's
what i'm going to advise everybody to do
you're staring at your leg you're like
why isn't it singing it's not flowing
what is up so we can try to do a few
things we can say
i'm all i'm going to do right now is i'm
going to hide stuff okay watch what
happens i'm going to take this
i'm going to hide it does it make the
layout better
is it still broken and like it's still
not great because the
the center column text here is not
really doing anything with this they're
kind of
not relating to one another they're not
speaking the same language
so if i start to let me remove this
okay now you look at that and you're
like is that interesting
handsome yeah it is
right so now we're we think this element
is good
maybe in its previous iteration when
you're hiding too much of it wasn't
so you need to see a little bit more of
the tops of
the e and a couple of other letters
because see this letter here that
the g you can't tell that's a g just yet
it could be a lowercase
a a weird a or something we just don't
know so by pushing it
into the frame we can get a better sense
of what it is now if you pull it too far
out
it may or may not lose that that tension
that's being created
on the left edge there so just be
mindful of that now let's bring
everything back
okay so now what we do is we're going to
do the opposite here i'm going to hide
this
i'm going to hide each one of these in
order here let me hide this
like this okay now that i bring this
back
is this okay now this in itself is not
bad
and this isn't bad but the two
together isn't really doing anything
this is where you may want to pay more
attention to alignment gridding and
spacing so when we talk about this
the order like we have the focal point
but how are these things related like
once i read resonate what am i supposed
to do here
this is where we need to start the
design right this works true like
in photoshop as it does in illustrator
turn off your layers
turn them back on one at a time and when
something doesn't feel right you've
identified
a problem so perhaps
this thing that you're doing here which
is kind of reminiscent of
how credits are displayed at the end of
a film
where they split the alignment they
align flush right and then flush left
and then they align things in that
that way that's kind of what you've
created here
so it feels to me like tony what we want
to do is make sure we understand how to
manipulate
and position type for impact for clarity
for clarity and for relationship and for
balance and harmony
and in this initial i felt like you
dropped three elements and you're like i
don't know what else to do
that's it okay so some things for you to
think about
i think the first thing i would do just
immediately is take all the stuff
and align it left
okay and ask yourself is this layout
better now there you go
i can breathe now do not hold your
breath when designing everybody
you'll turn blue in the face and it's
not good so the other thing that we need
to pay attention to is i'm going to draw
another box here
i'm going to grab this one
[Music]
okay and i'm going to draw a box and
kind of get a sense of proportion here
so if i take this and then
drop this down here okay so there's
about double
so you can see like we're creating weird
spacing in between all these things
all i want to do is pay attention to the
space in between these boxes like
the white space here and the white space
here so i'm going to delete these now
okay sometimes that helps so we just
want to try something we want to take
this and we want to say
what if we brought this closer to this
does it make this space more interesting
or dynamic
does reducing the number of elements
from
four things four groupings one two three
four
into three make it a little easier maybe
maybe not i don't know
chris if i may add to what you're saying
is that
before we have these boxes or
islands that they're floating around
and by you bringing the middle paragraph
to the bottom paragraph you're creating
proximity and proximity
is a good thing to create focal point
and versus the eye jumping around boom
boom boom because it's overwhelming for
the eye
to know where to go yeah when there's
these elements
floating around okay
so that's the other thing you can do is
if things feel complicated
make them simpler by grouping yes so
position or distance implies
relationship nice
if i put these two close together then
we look at this as their family they
belong together
and we should see them as one unit even
though they're made of many components
okay
and we can keep working on this so you
can also say like okay what else can we
do over here i'm gonna try something
okay all i'm gonna do is put a little
bit more space between resonate
and this and see like okay how does that
change things like does this make this
more interesting so yeah
starting to get three groups back this
really small one little dot on the page
a box and another box okay i forgot to
mention something i want you guys to
look at this let me hide this for a
second
if you were to look at this as a layout
just like you're doing abstract painting
post-modern kind of just boxes on a page
do those boxes look interesting to you
and if it doesn't look good like this
it's probably a good indicator
we need to work on the composition a
little bit more if you're enjoying these
critiques
inspired by the work you see and want to
get better at layout and design
for print web film or television we have
a course available
on our site that is designed just for
you it will help you to learn the rules
of typography
how to create contrast control focal
points achieve
asymmetrically beautiful layouts how to
critique your own work
keyboard shortcuts and include my
personal tips on how to build an asset
library so you
can design at the speed of thought as an
added bonus
students who are enrolled in the course
can participate in future critiques
get updates as we release them and a
time lapse video of me
working on layouts not available
anywhere else
you can jump in anytime work at your own
pace and take your typography skills
to the next level that's it for me i
hope to see you
in the future
you